if I solve that what will I get at the
end what result will I have it'll tell
me the place where the gradient of this
cubic curve okay is equal to now what
does this mean MX minus 4
well MX minus 4 is the it's the
y-coordinate of this line right so tell
me when the gray of the curvy thing is
the same as the y-coordinate of the
straight line is that useful great you
why court no it doesn't actually take
you anywhere right you might find it but
you're like okay like what does that
have to do with anything
the my position is the same as the rate
that I'm changing for some other
quantity okay so this turns out to be
not that useful either okay by the way
even though we haven't got anything
useful out of this yet this purse is
still important because they're ruling
stuff out okay what's left I want to
suggest not a faction that this is this
does have to be solved with something
okay the question is one what are we
going to make it equal to so this is the
gradient at this particular point okay
what is it going to be equal to well I
should know what this is equal to right
it should match the grainy of the line
right is that okay
what's the great end of the line
hmm now okay before we leave it's okay
this is true
I'm not subbing it into anything else
because that's gonna lead us to problems
okay
what I can say from this is therefore a
nice to have a in this room okay say
that makes sense right because x squared
the smallest it can be is zero right
so therefore the smallest M can be also
zero okay
and what's that correspond to the fact
that this has to be going up and make
sense execute is monotonically
increasing so therefore the line that we
should have should also have positive
gradient well that's nice but doesn't
give us an answer right because it's
obviously not true I mean if I put in M
equals 0 M equals zero
what kind of straight line do I have I
have a horizontal line okay so I have
this line doesn't look like much of a
tangent to me okay so this might be true
but it's definitely not all the answer
so what else can I do with this gradient
any others any takers
like a differentiate again that'd give
me concavity I think I'm going further
away let me put you out of your misery
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna show you my
solution and by the way I did what
you're doing right now I did it for
about 15 or 20 minutes and I was banging
my head on the wall and I thought why do
I miss you okay because I know this is
true but it's not enough so I'm gonna
walk you through my solution and then
you stop me at the point where you get
your aha moment okay and if I get to the
end without you ever getting in a
harmony with them that would be a shame
but that's okay at least you'll get the
answer so here's what we're gonna do it
maybe if you want to follow along you
can write this part down because this is
this is the way that I would solve it if
you've got this in trolley gym this is
what I would do
okay I want to say let the point
we're a wine is tangent to the curve
let it be now I want to put it at a
particular place okay
David this fish okay now I don't exactly
know where it is but that doesn't mean I
know nothing about it okay so for
instance let's say it's x value is K I
don't know what it is all right but if I
know what the x value is I'll know what
the Y value is - we're not
he fixed values K then the y value will
be K cubes right because y equals x
cubed all right so this is K K cubed
right that's an important point for us
that's what I'm gonna call this point of
intersection okay now the reason why
even though that's very simple in itself
is so that's so helpful is that I know
that this line has to pass through that
point and it also has to pass through
this point down here zero minus four
right so this is enough to help me work
out gradient right it passes through
that intercept and the point you just
made up okay now this is why it's just
so clever okay to get this question
right you can't just go forwards and
like differentiation differentiate again
or calculus or induction okay actually
go back it's a little bit back in eure
when we were first doing point geometry
right how do you figure out the gradient
of something well you need to know two
points that join you know and then you
can work out the greater the interval
right its rise rise over run okay so
therefore okay I can say M should be
equal to all right what is rise everyone
in this case rice cake use minus
negative 4 so plus 4 all over K minus 0
ok
now that's the gradient in terms of
these two points okay but I also know
that the gradient at that particular
point over there is equal to this right
because you differentiate okay so
therefore I should know that
ABB's also equal to 3x squared when X is
equal to K thank you see what's going on
I'm approaching about one value and I'm
appreciate from two different directions
the problem you guys had the reason why
our equations kept on going in secos is
because you were approaching em from one
angle and then you approach it from the
same angle that's why when you put them
together you get something which is
meaningless okay it's just like saying X
is equal to 2 X onto it's like what yeah
that's true but you don't get anything
meaningful out of it ok you got to come
from two different places all right this
week it's all ok so I can say 3 K
squared is equal to that ok so cut some
numbers multiply UK across you're gonna
get some K cubed over here and some K
kids over here so you're gonna have to
here and then there's just gonna be this
number four over here then you divide by
two and you're gonna get this sorry
that's three okay so k is the cube root
of 2 now stop for a second does that
make sense
what would it indicate over here what is
the cube root of 2 I don't know
1.2 something 1.3 yeah okay so yeah that
kind of makes sense all right at least
it's going off in the right direction
and if K is equal a cubed which mean
this is upper - yeah that seems
consistent okay now what we're actually
interested in the value of M right so
how do I find that
right okay because racking up M and K
are linked in this way okay so even
though it's a bit awkward because you've
got a cube root that you're squaring
they probably the easiest way to write
it is M is equal to three times okay
which is a cube root so that's to the
power of 1/3 right so I guess I'd call
that to 2/3 that's it thank you thank
you for I did ask you to tell me so
that's some yeah okay well actually yeah
I don't know if I should be upset that
you only got it right at the end where
Russia grew up more upset but everyone
else still hasn't gotten there you
explained it so badly that even with
anyone okay say you like this this
there's the question okay